yeah go ahead we have with us proost uh
Jones excellent thank you very much
representative lad and and thanks for
inviting us here today to to provide you
an update the two-page document in front
of you is is a summary of the work that
we did in our first year and what I'd
like to do today is walk through that as
well as let you know kind of what's
happened this fall and where I think uh
we will be by the by the end of December
is is the goal so hb1 1530 is really
centered on addressing this problem of
uh community college students having
very clear pathway Pathways that can be
communicated to students in high school
so that they see both a lower cost path
if they want to use the Community
College on their way to uh usnh and a
bachelor's degree uh but also many
students in fact I was I was just at at
an association of public and land grant
universities for the last couple days I
just got back last night and went to an
entire session where this is being
discussed across the country that about
65 % of the community college students
don't necessarily know what path they
want to be on so they need to have
better guidance when they get into the
community college so how do we give them
that guidance and then the third thing
that I think is equally important is to
make sure that we have a map a map of
where are those degree opportunities and
how do they line up with the workforce
needs of the state um so three
committees came excuse me just for a
second I was negligent Mark do you want
to come up and and be here at the same
time because this is all it's it's a
collect effort of both twoe and fouryear
system and I apologize for leaving the
visual um to that point the first thing
we did when HB hb1 1530 was passed was
we pulled together a team a team led by
uh lesie barber in the Chancellor's
office at ccsnh and Kate zemer uh who is
uh the senior Vice proost for academic
Affairs at Una representing the usnh
system um those two working with faculty
and staff across both systems created
three committees the three committees
were really looking to explore um what
transfer programs were going to be most
appropriate to pursue many many of those
programs are very very appropriate to
transfer kind of nursing to nursing very
straightforward um though there are some
complications I'll discuss others uh for
example if you're going for um auto
mechanics or large equipment operation
that exists at ccsnh there is no
parallel for a bachelor's degree um and
then the third area was to explore
existing Pathways as a definition I
would say there are two different ways
of looking at Pathways one approach to
Pathways is to think about it as very
very linear so you start out with an
accounting major at the community
college system that transfers course by
course by course through to a bachelor's
degree at one of the usn campuses those
Pathways have existed for years between
our two systems um but they're they're
one by one by one so we have seven
different community college campuses we
have three different usnh campuses
that's three times seven 21 different M
us that have to be signed for every
degree path it's not realistic another
pathway approach is to have a universal
pathway and that's been our Target in
the work that we've been doing on
1530 the second area which is also very
very interested is a block grant and the
block grant takes two forms so the so
imagine that when you get your
associates degree from ccsnh that
automatically transfers Lock Stock and
Barrel into a degree path in one of the
usnh institutions again there's two
flavors of that one is that it is the
entire major the other is that it is
just the general education requirements
which is fulfilled for the most part in
the first two years so it's it's very
very reasonable of those four Pathways
the middle two is where we're focusing
our energy and in particular the
universal Pathways so the idea that if
you come in and you know you want to
study nursing that there is a very clear
pathway all the way through what you'll
see on the second page of the report so
that would be this list uh not
highlighted in yellow but if you look
carefully you can almost see um this
list represents our Target Pathways It
lines up very very well with the
workforce needs in the state at this
time we have completed Universal
Pathways for 10 of those programs uh and
the electronic version of this show you
which 10 I can actually yeah that' be
nice if we could have that you we could
check them all yeah so I will tell you
I'm going to read them off to you so
nursing yeah business management
psychology Human Services business
administration accounting and finance
healthc Care Management Information
Technology English and history those are
the ones that were completed as of the
time of the writing of this report I
will tell you we have seven more that we
believe are going to be completed by the
end of December and we are well on track
to complete all of them within the two
years of the hb1 1530 Bill and we'll be
updating you as we go do you have a list
of those seven that you're are those
still I do not have that with me
confidential uh it's not that they're
confidential it's that I just don't have
the data in front of me uh it's
certainly welln
unfortunately uh lesie Barber and Kate
Zer were not able to be with us today so
uh Mark and I are poor second choices uh
to try and address your questions but I
can get that to you and will uh at the
end of December as soon as I I have that
list um we have run into some bumps many
of those bumps are centered on faculty
and and we're working through them one
at a time the community college system
you want to say something about the you
know pulling your faculty together in
the summer and the work that they did
there Mark I think uh that's a good
model and something we want to plug into
yeah again the last couple of Summers
we've
used last couple of Summers we've
engaged our faculty uh disciplinary
teams from across the seven colleges to
take a look at our curriculum identify
those courses that are equivalent try
and remove what are sometimes
inconsistencies or or barriers within
our system so that we can identify
courses that are are comparable and and
should flow through both our system into
the university system
seamlessly um so we're actually trying
to build on that model one of the things
that started right before hb1 1530 but
hb1 1530 really put a bow on it was we
wanted to have better collaboration
between our campuses so uh working with
uh Kristen Miller at um White Mountain
White Mountains Community College uh
We've now pulled together a provos
council that is the provos of all of the
system campuses both the seven ccsn and
the three usnh and to be clear on the
usnh system they're called tros and vice
president for academic Affairs at the
community college they're all the vice
president for academic Affairs sometimes
with student affairs uh linked in there
we're now meeting every other month on
this topic and we're talking about how
do we get faculty together in the summer
this coming summer to Leverage What the
community college has been doing and get
some faculty from usnh there I'm very
excited about that I think the the
trickiest spot that we've run into is
how do we get the faculty more familiar
with one another because the block grant
requires more of that familiarity um
we've also been working on the transfer
Pathways and there's some technology
that we need to put in place to make it
more effective so there's um some
transfer softway I think we I'm going to
walk into the second part of this when I
talk about transfer Pathways so I'm not
sure I want to tell you everything on
that front now or we'll walk through
that separately um I will say we're very
excited about the work uh we know that
the total number of students
transferring from the community college
into the four-year college has declined
but we were very excited at the last
usnh uh uh Board of Trustees meeting we
were looking at the data and we realized
that actually the CC the usnh market
share of the ccsnh graduates has gone up
a little bit in recent years and we want
to keep increasing that that's the goal
we want to
pursue I'll stop there and see if
there's any questions on that part
before we talk about some of the other
trans transfer pathway work yes
representa thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for that I'm just sort of
interested in these Majors that you had
us check off are they first in line
because of enrollment and interest of
the student body that's my first
question and then second is I see
Elementary Ed next to social studies but
I'm curious where uh future teachers are
in the priority list for your Pathways
thank you both are great questions uh
the answer is yes the first thing we did
was we mapped all of the community
college majors and we mapped all of the
majors that they go into when they go to
usnh uh so part of that Target list
comes from that because we wanted to we
didn't want to spend an enormous amount
of time going after Majors that didn't
have a clear connection and there
weren't a lot of students in there so
that's why um in fact if you go if you
go three slides into the transfer
pathway there's a chart that shows
enrollment uh the enrollment chart that
we looked at that has nursing at the
top business management psychology those
are the three largest enrolled Majors
coming from
ccsnh there are some opportunities to
pursue some of these degrees that go
more specifically into Elementary and
secondary Ed um we now have a task force
that was pulled together by the provos
at usnh to explore kind of all those
path Pathways and the next step is to
take that to the ccsnh partnership um we
have some work to do there uh we
literally met with commissioner Ed blue
and um several members of his staff uh
late October was when we did that I
don't remember the exact date and uh the
23rd thank you Kathy and uh they were
very enthusiastic about us uh pulling
that group together and we reported on
that on November 7th when we met with
the uh Community College vice presidents
and so there was lots of enthusias
often times with
education there are many other Majors
that take you into education education
is the certification it's the top off
right so you come in as a math major you
come in as a as a social science or a
history major and then you get your
Education certification on top anything
you want to share on the education side
from the community college
side I I I have a question for you and
unfortunately it's on the second page of
our minutes and I have a copy here you
don't have it there because didn't get
copied upstairs
but I'm going to read this this
paragraph right here it followed uh when
we were discussing this you were giving
us a background on on education from
World War II onwards and but I'll read
this the university uh New Hampshire
system un nsnh
University New Hampshire system it must
be and Community College system New
Hampshire also provided a verbal update
regarding the status and progress of HB
1530 established curricular transfer
Pathways between the community college
system of New Hampshire and the
university system of New
Hampshire progress is being made toward
this end an updated report will be made
with the community college system of New
Hampshire and the and the university
system New Hampshire in June committee
members did ask and here's one of the
questions which we asked who decides if
course credit is accepted from one one
institution to another Wayne Jones
responded that is it is the Department's
and staff within the department that
make the decision the committee
indicated concern should an accredited
course earned at one institution
institution be accepted at another
members Express this scenario has been a
concern for years and I believe the
senator does not here was one to ask
this and with full implementation of HB
1530 students may have a better
understanding of credit
transferability especially within the
community college system New Hampshire
and University system New Hampshire
Institution
further discussion will occur upon
receipt of the written status report
which we're receiving right now so the
question is that we are alluding to is
that if you're taking a math course with
you and you're accredited and it's an
accredited
course why then if it's if the
accrediting is being done by the same
institution down in Boston or wherever
why is that not accepted at your level
or yeah at your level you mind if I take
a go with this yeah so this has been the
process we've been going through with
our faculty you would normally think for
instance first year composition uh
College um algebra for instance and pick
your course is a relatively standard
each course has specific learning
outcomes and what we've been asking our
faculty to do across the college is
confirm that the learning outcomes for
each of these courses are in fact the
same learning outcomes that the courses
aren't simply similar or comparable in
name but actually are achieving the same
result in some disciplines that may be
less uh clearcut than others but for
instance if you're looking at a sequence
of math courses without having assurance
that the core competencies in this
course are the foundation for the course
that follows you don't want to set a
student up for failure so what we're
asking our faculty to do in this process
is ensure the learning outcomes for the
courses are in fact the same learning
outcomes
without that background work being done
by The Faculty you could find yourself
in a circumstance where the course
really isn't comparable and the students
preparation for what follows is
insufficient if I could if I could just
pile on one thing an important point of
to acknowledge is there's different
accreditations so when we talk about the
New England Commission on higher
education Nei that is our primary
accrediting body they accredit on behalf
of the Department of Education but they
don't look course by course they look
for do you have the learning outcomes
defined they don't compare them they
just say do you have them defined and
they look for continuous Improvement how
are you getting how are you getting
feedback that is continuously letting
you improve your courses improve your
curriculum some Majors have separate
accreditation that that we hold that
requires that digs deeper digs into the
course level the text level what exactly
is is is the student reading and doing
and we have to meet those for example in
business we are aacp accredited that's a
top accrediting body and they don't even
accredit at the community college level
so there's a there's a gap there that's
where we need the faculty to do exactly
what Mark described we're challenging
our faculty to do the same as his and
we're asking them to talk to one another
so that we make sure they're lining up
wherever possible I I will say that the
heart of that question is is Central to
a lot of our conversations we're trying
to remove barriers for students h B 1530
gives us a framework to pursue that but
our accredit our accreditation through
Nei still requires that faculty have
control over the curriculum if you will
authority to determine that the learning
outcomes of this course brought in from
another institution in fact satisfy the
requirements of their
programs Prof SM you had a question yeah
I have uh five area questions you just
returned from a national meeting how
many states have a similar program that
what we have here as far as the metric
automatic matriculation into schools
from community
colleges I can't give you specific
statistics uh some uh systems are
combined uh for example the Sunni system
is a system I'm very familiar with the
community college is part of the same
system others are separated just like
ours are others have multiple State
systems so North Carolina there's
there's the state system there's a UNCC
system and then there's the community
college system so there's mixes um all
of them right now are talking about how
do we build these types of Pathways and
these types of block transfers
uh I would based on my discussions less
than certainly less than half probably
less than a the third actually have them
already built so it would be fair to say
that New Hampshire is somewhat ahead of
the
the head of the curve as it relates to
I'm not sure I go that it's a steep
curve um I I would look at States like
California Virginia and Florida that are
probably decades ahead of us on some of
these things yeah and they tend to have
very wellestablished uh systems with you
know in some cases common course
numbering that flows between the
community college system University
system so the student knows that it's
not only this course by name but by
number course lives at every
institution next question is how are
students
notified of this particular opportunity
for them to do this automatic
matriculation uh so after they achieve
their associate degree so what's the
process of making sure that they're
aware that and do they and when do they
give notice that they want to do
that well we we use this as an advising
tool with students when they come on
board that if you're interested in a
four-year degree through the university
system this is the pathway for this
program so it's part of the advising in
fact it's part of the recruiting
opportunity when prospective students
are considering that the community colle
system what one of the things that is
being discussed right now as part of our
working groups is how do we do that
communication better how do we get it to
start in high school so that high school
students know that this is an option um
but we also very much need to have the
partnership of the advisers at the
community colleges because so many
students 65% of students are going to
change their mind and change their path
while they're in courses at the
community college so it's kind of an
ongoing thing that we have to support I
I would submit that uh even at the high
school level of counseling there as far
as where students might want to go
that's another opportunity to at least
because there may be some students say
no I I don't want I'm not a I'll get my
associate degree because I want want to
get a particular badge or a particular
uh
certification and the counselor at the
high school I would say look at here's
another opportunity for you to do that
plus go ahead I'm not here for a sales
call today but I'm going to use the
opportunity this is at the heart of our
interest in expanding duel and
concurrent enrollment early early
college program if we can assist
students and families in
seeing both the benefit of opport and
affordability while they're still in
high school not just to take courses
randomly but to take a structured entry
into these Pathways while still in high
school not only do I think it will help
with affordability and access of
postsecondary Education I think it's one
of the ways in which we can increase the
likelihood that students who are already
thinking about college but often think
about leaving the state to do that will
find their way to our system and to the
university system through those Pathways
I I think we can make this not just a
close to grad uation here's a pathway
but embedded in grades 10 11 and 12 as a
real core opportunity streng thank you
the next area I wanted to pursue is
staff
quality uh there historically has been
an arrogance around higher uh four-year
colleges Visa that of two-year colleges
and so as you begin to look at
uh the next area I'm going to talk about
is content but leading into content uh
how have you been been able to deal with
that
arrogance uh about quality of staff at
the higher at the four-year institutions
Visa that of the two-year institutions
making sure that um these the staff at
the two-year institutions are not in
competition with those at the four-year
institutions so the question is is to me
is that how is the quality of uh monitor
at the two-year institutions as relates
to dealing with the four in fouryear
institutions want go first or you want
to go
first you you I I'll go first on that
one um you know I when you start asking
that question about quality and my mind
turns to dson cofman and Kim Pera two of
our nursing program directors at Great
Bay and at
Manchester Peter L Monica and Dan relle
a couple of Faculty members in it and in
advanced manufacturing at
Manchester uh e globber nursing faculty
at River Valley quality faculty members
preparing students I think I've talked
to this group before other certainly
other House and Senate
committees five years in a row New
Hampshire has a distinction of the
highest firsttime enclex pass rate for
associate prepared nurses anywhere in
the
country that doesn't happen by accident
it happens because we have faculty
committed to their discipline committed
to their students committed to the to
the work that they do as as Educators
and that type of quality is reflected
across the curriculum for our students
so I'm not worried at all about quality
well I shouldn't say I I'm not concerned
that quality isn't being met we worried
about quality but not that it isn't
being
met I think I would second uh that I'm
not worried about quality at the
community college system more at the
four-year uh college system but I
acknowledge that some and especially
historically there's been this this
arrogance for different job types you
know if you are a professor at at UNH uh
that is has responsible ability not just
for teaching classes but also for doing
research and and working in partnership
with the state and other organizations
that is a very very different task than
being a faculty member at a four-year
college or at a community college
we recruit nationally and we recruit
faculty that have terminal degrees and
experience in the field and all of our
campuses do a great job I think of doing
that where we need to do a better job
and where I'm very very pleased is we
need to be sharing that data and getting
the communication going between the
faculty I think the enlex is a great
example that passage rate is the same
passage rate that we worry about at the
four-year college and so when our
four-year College faculty see that
two-year College faculty hitting those
numbers hitting those marks they gain
confidence in one another the last thing
I'll say
is our faculty are a distribution they
are not a monolith and we will never
eliminate arrogance any more than we
will eliminate um faculty that
underperform and are removed as a result
of our our annual or three year or
fiveyear reviews depending upon what
their rank is um the bulk of our fact
faculty however value and are working on
these learning outcomes and when we can
get those learning outcomes aligned and
we can have the faculty working together
to get them aligned then they have
confidence in one another and I think
that's that's how you move the needle
and I think that's the work we're doing
right now thank you that moves me into
the next area you talked earlier about
um competency targets uh within
respective courses Etc so is that the
way is that the way that you guarantee
the quality of the content at the 2-year
institutions as students are looking for
a particular major Etc is it the is that
the competency questions that provide
the continuity between the institutions
it's I don't think it's necessarily
competency I think we have competency at
at all levels I think what we need to do
is make sure that the learning outcomes
being taught within the competency of
the faculty member align with what's NE
needed for those later level courses
so as I think about it I think about um
we do not want to set a student up to
fail at the next level and you can have
a very competent faculty member teaching
a first year course that just doesn't
cover all the topics because there's not
as comfortable with it and then at the
next level because that course gets
transferred we don't get covered that's
why you got to get the faculty together
and make sure they're covering the same
learning competencies thank you learning
out and and thank you for uh taking my
questions the final One deals with is
there a c this is the last one right it
is the last one yes good is is there a
is there a certain grade point that a
student has to have in order for that uh
for them to qualify uh transferring it
to uh the fouryear
institution yes uh so if you're chance
transferring generic credit you have to
have a passing grade of I think it's see
see or better yeah see or better now
coming back to one of your earlier
questions and embellishing a little bit
on what Mark said Mark is absolutely
right the the those systems that do this
the best get their course numbering
lined up that's a heavy lift the next
level is when within your pathway you
can define a degree a grade level that
automatically transfers in so California
has been working in some of their
Pathways to say well if you're coming
out of the Community College with a b or
better or a B+ or better you're
automatically emitted into the next
level to transfer right into the system
I think those are discussions that are
going on right now that's that's where
we want to go thank you for answering my
questions and I'd like to follow up on
on the business here of the the uh the
ab C D or what your point average might
be I know that when I went to college
for my B bachelor's
degree a c was really tough to get in
some areas because you know that
now the level of Competency of some of
those I see coming out with A's or a 4.0
it's not a whole lot better than those
that came out with a 2.0 back in the
days so what kind of criteria and
competency are you using to say this is
a 3.0 or this is you know wherever it
might be and or is it still pretty much
subjective based upon professor
professor Mooney here that this is what
I see as a you know an average grade or
this is a superlative grade right here
is there criteria established or not so
between the the two systems so between
the two systems no great inflation has
been a problem for decades yeah it's a
problem in the K through 12 system it's
a problem at the community college it's
a problem in higher education across the
country um those places where we have
the clearest learning outcome set is
where you get the best correlation with
grades there is some subjectivity to it
particularly in some disciplines um it's
something that I worry about I look at
grade reports every single semester and
we have conversations with Department
chairs and with with the Deans about hey
is is this really the the trend that we
want to have um I think it's something
we're going to continue to work on it is
hard to go back and compare what you can
do and what we encourage all of our
faculty to do is take advantage of
nationally standardized tests whenever
possible so that we have some Benchmark
to compare to and at the four-year
colleges we also rely on our external
evaluations for disciplinary peers that
come in the American Chemical Society
the American physical Society uh the
nursing CCN comes in and they do Deep
dive evaluations on most of our majors
and their they're looking for how is it
doing compared to other universities
across the country so that's the other
way we try and balance it but it's an
issue and we have to pay attention to
now I I would imagine it would be in
this last part in this up that I have
but I I look at for example the
enrollment at maybe the community
college system you're probably going to
have a higher age bracket person coming
into the community college
system who is also looking for specific
skill orientation so they can be out in
Industry um they may not be good at
taking a practice that we have as
teachers have to take but they may know
how to teach they may know how to fix
that and pull that wrench and do what
they need to um so H how is how is this
being gauged you know I know I I I think
I understand you know that part in terms
of coming out of and working at the
community cous but are are those
programs at the four-year system
recognizing that there's different
styles of learning and there's different
you know and a person may be able to do
it it maybe just Mr Brown that can teach
just as well as Dr Brown um so so the
grades the grades transfer as long as a
see or better they
transfer and and so so bottom line yes
it's being recognized from the community
we're going take a break and welcome
Senator delandro to our meeting today I
hope the traffic wasn't too bad out
there
have to drive
upce we're talking about transferability
of programs from one level to the next
years well it sounds like we're moving
now so where were we here uh you were
asking about uh grade transferability
and and is is a c a 3.0 the same at
system
what I will say is we accept the grade
in transfer as long as it's above a seat
are they equivalent for some students
yes for other students no but we don't
get down to the individual course level
in making those
decisions are there any other questions
here I I do have one more I'm looking at
nursing right at the top of it and I'm
sitting beside a nurse
here
um if you're a nurse and you've you're
coming out and you have that two-year
ticket
to be a nurse and and you'd like to go
on and maybe get into biomedicine or to
some other aspect of the medical field
Audiology um are your courses that you
took I don't want to call them Jed but
they're pretty specific to
nursing anywhere you do are those going
to be accepted in the other program it
might be somebody that's majoring in
nursing at the fouryear system are those
basic courses going to be approved
for the that other degree so are they
transferable within the system and
between
systems so the I want to make sure that
I'm I'm answering the question that
you're asking uh so you're saying this
is a student that's been successful
taking their uh associates degree in
nursing and they now want to transfer
into a four-year college but they're
going to Pivot a little bit because
they're they're attracted they want to
go into to uh other Allied Health fields
and so the question is will those
courses transfer in into that other
field biomed biomedical engineering or
something uh the answer is right now
they would come over as general credit
and then the advisor would go through
the transcript and say which ones count
and which ones don't if they get off
their if they go to a different pathway
for example um the math that you would
need for an associates degree in nursing
it's not the same math you would need to
Pivot into an engineering field if you
wanted to go to medic biomedical
engineering that's okay we can we'll
take that in that advising conversation
and say you know all of these transfer
you get the general education credits
but now you have to take this additional
map of course those conversations take
place what we'd like to do as we work on
these Pathways and nursing is a great
example is make sure that we have the
pathway defined so that some of those
shifts are defined for the student
before they come across cross so for
example let's pick on nursing there are
several Allied Health programs that take
all of those nursing credits right
across and we know that now because
we've looked at them but if you get too
far a field you might have to pick up an
additional MTH we'd like to be able to
define those sooner for the students so
they know it before they before they
complete their time in the community
questions okay yes
Senator transferability has been a
significant
problem through throughout our system
which I've never really understood to be
honest with you and as I said we worked
on we worked on this for years um
Governor Peterson and I were on this
Commission in in in today's world we
have limited space particularly let's
let's refer to the nursing situation so
you get an associate degree at say at
the community any college level and you
want to transfer to a
BSN and first of all spaces is is a
problem but if you can't move everything
that you've taken at the associate
degree level and you have to repeat or
or get certain courses what what you're
doing is extending the time for that for
that individual and there's a cost
situation involved in that because the
kid went to the to to the initial
program
to get the associate degree and don't
have to expedite you know you know
moving
forward but the but the problem I see is
the kid gets discouraged when they bring
that transcript to you and and we talk
about Allied Health this this and this
and and the kid finds out gez I I've got
60 credits that for my associate degree
and all of a sudden half of them half of
them don't fit and I got to retake them
or or do something or or do something
else can't can't we create some kind of
a of a a Synergy between the associate
degree programs and what we expected for
the baloran degree because the law now
says you got to have a baloran degree I
I worked on a situation recently where
we we're allowing you know regular irns
to practice and not to get their BS
until a later date but we're putting
pressure on people to get more education
it and yet we're stabing them attribut
to transferability Senator going to
drawn 17 years in the University of New
Hampshire and other seven with grand
state for coming commity college system
we have relatively few instances where a
student would find that kind of a
derailing
situation unless a student is making a
significant change where their associate
degree was in business but now they want
engineering or their associate degree
was in nursing and now they want
engineering in almost any program that's
generally aligned there may still be
some small disruptions there but using
nursing as the example the the longest
um established program 3 plus1 RN to BSN
between the two systems allows a student
in the community college system to
finish not just the associate degree but
the third year toward the fouryear
degrees and in transferring to the
university system through what is now
College of professional studies not only
having all of those courses flow through
but actually retaining the community
colle system tuition rate to finish that
degree so there are some very
well-crafted Pathways and relatively few
situations like the one that you and
Governor Peterson began to try and
overcome 30 years ago we've gotten if if
you don't mind if you would go to page
two the third page in your pack has a
list next
one yeah that
list uh so that is the list of the
pathways right now now as it was a time
of the writing this report 10 of those
now have those Pathways defined exactly
the way you want it to be there's six or
seven more coming on by the end of
December and we will complete this
entire list by the end of next
year just just so you know I think a key
point and and you you implied it but I
want to call it out another part of this
to make sure we're not costing students
more money is we have to get that
advising to them sooner we need to let
them know that pathway exists and if
they take these courses in sequence at
the community college then they will be
able to graduate within that foure
window that you talked about I I'll also
remind that the language in House Bill
1530 describes the optimizing the
affordability and utility of the
community college system so in some ways
like the 3+ one maybe not quite as
clearly as 3+1 what we had anticipated
students could progress within the
community col system Beyond just 60
credits to fully Leverage The the
alignment that's being created
capitalize on the convenience the access
the quality as well as the affordability
transition that's that's great that's
great news but I I'm thinking of now uh
St Joseph's wanted an associate degree
program so I fixed that for them so they
they got the associate degree now how
will those people
how how do we make sure that they can
move through this portal in in in the
same fashion because it seems to me with
the shortage that's that's occurring all
over the country that these nursing
schools that shut down themselves you
know that they all had nursing schools
we had nursing school at at New
Hampshire hospital and all of a sudden
we we let it go now they reinstituting
them now who oversees their situation
and how does that kid make a make a
trans position or is it covered so at
the four-year College we we all of our
campuses have uh transfer portals that
you can come through right now we're
working in collaboration with ccsnh to
to have a common portal so that that
that exists the course equivalencies
exist for many different institutions
that we probably have about a 100
different institutions Mark was at un
when we were setting the beginning of
those up uh so a student coming from a
St Anum if they wanted to transfer in
absolutely could and where that course
equivalency already exists is taken care
of if it isn't we go through and we do
the course byour checking uh to help
through so there where my head is going
is is into nursing where I think we have
a bigger challenge right now that high
school students aren't choosing to go
into nursing our the number of
applications across our systems into
nursing is going down and so we have a
broader National and Statewide problem
of of how we make that degree path more
attractive is that I thought we were at
a a point where we had more I thought we
were at this peak here are we now going
back down from that Peak that's what
we're seeing at the four-year College I
don't know the Community College data
but that is what we're seeing across the
country at foure college that pandemic
had a detrimental effect on healthare
interest in careers I mean it's create a
lot of wear and tear on those folks who
are there and I think it has dissuaded
many people who are interested I'll
offer you an interesting uh fact though
last year we had 416 students enrolled
in our nursing programs across the
community college system 79 of them
already held a bachelor's degree in some
other discipline so our nursing students
have always been uh
somewhat older uh group than traditional
age students coming typically from other
career paths and in that regard I still
think we'll we'll find students who have
the interest not necessarily coming
directly out of high school but but
folks who recognize that calling later
in life okay before we go with a whole
lot more questions um we're nearing 11
o'clock yeah I'm I'm watching
I wrap it in five minutes that would be
great um are there any areas that you
would like to speak to before you have
to get out of here Wayne it turns out
the questions have taken us through I
think many of the things that we're
working on for transfer Pathways I'm
very very appreciative of the
collaboration with the community college
system at our at our last provos council
meeting this is the group of all the
provos and vice president for academic
Affairs for all of our campuses at ccs
and usnh we all said to ourselves you
know we need to think more carefully
about how we communicate this
partnership out and so we'll be working
with Mark and with Kathy and and others
to think about how we do that
communication
I'm going to rec represent Mooney here
in a second but my my last thing before
you head out over 60% of our kids go
outside the state of New Hampshire to go
to college
University are we going to get some
transfer Pathways to have kids from
UMass l or from UMaine
Oro Southern Maine all those colleges
around us in universities say Hey you
can you we'll we'll we'll transfer your
credits in here and we'll take you as a
junior or whatever to get those kids
coming back to our state where are we on
Miss uh we do that in fact so the number
of transfer students at UNH increased by
nearly five and a half percent this year
most of it was New Hampshire residents
that had left the state and decided to
come back and so what we're discussing
now is how do we do more advertising and
more promotion in that space we
literally created a program where we
communicated with all of the students
that were admitted to UNH last year that
did not choose to come we invited them
to come back and offer them the same
trans the the same financial aid package
if they wanted to come back to New
Hampshire I think we have to do more
creative things like that it's not a
curricular problem the curricular
transfers pretty smoothly it's more of a
making sure that they feel welcomed and
that they feel that there's a place for
them to
go represent money did you have a
question yes thank you very much Mr
chairman and the senator reminds me of
something very key to all of this I
think and that is on the high school
level the guidance Department keeps a
very close track of the students ideally
even divided by alphabetical names so
that they know uh who's on track to
graduate the idea being that there is no
major surprise a month or a semester
before graduation that this student is
not uh qualified because they're missing
a course or they don't have the proper
grade Etc to avoid that surprise so I
guess my question is to avoid the
surprise of having all of these credits
and doing all these things and then it
doesn't go through who my question is I
guess two ways first who right now is
keeping track of that and you did
mention the keyword advising so that's
going on and then second of all if it's
necessary where in this bill would it be
that they would be advised and tracked
essentially to avoid any major
disastrous surprise at the end of their
journey I offer that one one thing to
know about our students is about 70% of
them are part-time students so the pace
at which they go through is a reflection
of their lives and so stopping in
restarting so it's not necessarily one
semester what might look like the next
semester me in fact be a year
out Pro for for our students register is
probably the person most aware of what
the students progress is toward a degree
and their advisor I think what provos
Jones described earlier was some
software solutions that we may look at
that would allow a student to actually
map their degree progress not just to
complete the degree with us but the
alignment toward the transfer into the
university system there's a product that
the university system is adopting now
that one of our campuses has already uh
initiated that may prove to be a
solution that allows us to have a little
bit more surveillance and vigilance on
that
Senator just have a comment I want to
make a plug for the nursing program I
think a lot of people don't know what a
nurse does and if two years of
nursing opens up a field and there are
so many different areas within nursing
that you can go you can go for your
Balor and you can be a floor nurse but
you have Specialties within nursing you
have IV nurses that are just fantastic
setting drips and whatever you have
pediatric nursing you have clinical
nursing you have nurses who work in the
community clinics so I think that it
would behooves us to let people know
what does being a nurse mean it doesn't
mean just one thing it's a whole field
that is uh is opened and it I think the
two years gives you basic understanding
of what's going on but it does not
prepare you for all of these other areas
and you have to continue maybe some of
your basic stuff you already know but
you need to go into more depth you need
to have more clinical understanding more
anatomy and physiology you need to
understand more about systems in order
to to progress and I think if that opens
up and I think people see the
opportunities I think that that's uh
it's going to go long
ways that's why I have this Cardiology
me yes represent my student population
is
declining competition is out
there how are you dealing with that so
the so there was a a study done around
2012 13 that that we've been tracking uh
Professor named Gro uh published a very
nice report that talks about the
demographic Cliff the demographic Cliff
is hitting different states differently
but in New England we're getting hit
hard he projected in 2015 that we see it
we would see a decline of about 17 to
18% overall in the number of students
graduating from high school and choosing
to go to college notice those are two
separate pieces both going in the wrong
direction um they hit campuses
differently community colleges get hit
differently than four year colleges get
hit differently than research centers
where are we today in New England is
we're about two-thirds of the way
through the decline it has hit different
campuses differently as we look at that
same data going forward what do we see
we see that we're we're kind of as for
four-year colleges we are probably at
about the level we're going to be 10
years from now so we've hit a point
where we can say all right let's this is
going to be our size how do we deal with
it over the next 10 years however
between in the next 10 years we're going
to see a wave that goes up for a couple
years and then we're going to see it
drop down for a couple of years and then
it's going to come back so that we have
this sine wave coming through the
challenges in New England particularly
for four-year colleges and Mark can
speak to the two-year
colleges how do we make sure we're built
for the right size and I believe that
size is about where we are now and then
not grow inappropriately for the next
couple years while while the wave goes
up and be in a position where we can
strategically invest so so that when the
wave goes down again we remain stable
and keep improving the quality of
Education like we've always done I'm
going to approach this question a little
bit differently and and disagree a
little bit in the sense I I would make
the case that the need for postsecondary
education is going to be greater over
the next 20 years than it has been just
because of the pace of change in
technology the changes in Industry
creation of
biofabrication as an industry in New
Hampshire something that didn't exist 20
years ago is going to create great
demand the need for succession in
virtually every industry is going to
require more education but it's not
going to be 18-year-old high school
graduates that part is accurate I'm
going to say that specific to the
18-year-old high school graduates one of
the things this October most recent
report on free and reduced lunch
Statewide 24% of children K 12 are
eligible for that Manchester close to
50% Franklin almost
60% Berlin Claremont you go through the
state and you can find places where 30
40 50% students so the need for
affordability so even though the number
of 18y olds may begin to level out the
need for access to Affordable
postsecondary education for that group
is going to be greater it's going to put
more pressure on both the university
system but the community college system
and these Pathways and the running Start
programs to allow us to help students
make that leap right now community
college system almost 40% of our
enrollment is 25 or older and going back
to the example of nurses who come to
that career later than post High School
I think we're going to see more students
more adult Learners who going to need
more education over time shorter
programs where they live online
accessible so they can continue with
their families with their jobs with
their lives while they prepare for
whatever comes next so I think that that
there's a demographic turn that 18y olds
but the broader picture of our state's
demographics I think produces a much
more complicated view of postsecondary
for US
senator thank you have you finish bill I
I think two things that occur to me are
a the competition is dramatic I've seen
the UMass ads and I know
MBI okay so you got a congressman who's
now the president of of the University
who
uh selling that University with
significant resources so that a that
competition we talk about this we're the
second oldest state in the United States
all right so unless we get a surge of of
of people and I we're going to have a
problem for an extended period of time
so a
competition price becomes significant I
was listening to NPR this morning you've
held the price again uh it's stable for
for what 25 24 25 right so so that that
news that that news was on the uh was on
the radio this morning so uh the nature
the nature of the Beast is is is
changing we're we're in a highly
competitive market now when I was a when
I was a a student in high school coming
UNH was
like Primo if you got into UNH you were
really
on top of the world and and uh now now I
see you can get into main Connecticut
Rhode Island Massachusetts and the
competition is is fierce I never in in
my life thought I'd see Billboards
announcing College come here because
it's cheaper or it's I mean I I see
those all all over and and U does that
denigrate the qu the the idea of of
Education we're selling it like a
product you know uh I mean I I see it it
it it's disturb it's disturbing to me to
to see a billboard that says come here
because it's cheaper never mind quality
I mean if I would love to see a
billboard say how about a beer truck
with gold black bears inside of it this
is you know this come because it's a
wonderful school you're going to get a
great education and your chances of of
doing better in life uh I I just think
the the competition in my opinion is
fierce you got to go way quickly so I
have to go I'm you address I'm gonna
give a a quick response and a and a
brief wrap I I worry about that too I
worry about that for our society I think
the most important thing we could do is
focus on the value of the education and
something UNH is very proud of is the
three years in a row now we've been in
the top 10 in the country for Best Value
in public higher education in the
country I I think that the price Wars
for lack of a better phrase and the
change in student Behavior at the 18 to
24 year old level have caused some of
that shift I think the future is going
to be thinking more broadly about the
other things that the university brings
to the table 20% of our students are
graduate students getting master's
degrees and phds 20,000 students took
advantage of individual courses and took
advantage and of extension programs
professional development and training
those are areas where we're having a
massive impact and we need to grow that
and it's a revenue stream I answered
your question directly but my colleague
could not be more correct that there's
lots of growth elsewhere we grew the
number of transfer students we grew the
number of graduate students we grew the
number of students taking professional
development training and getting micro
credentials and certificates that I
think is where we have to focus for the
future I'll finish with just one brief
comment and that's a thank you to to my
colleague at CCN SNH
and the teams that have been doing this
work I didn't do any of this work lesie
and Kate on our team and all the faculty
working on each of those degree programs
have done a great job and they're
embracing it you know the arrogance that
we referred to earlier we're not seeing
it I think that we're seeing
collaboration and that's the way we're
going to be successful thank you Wayne I
I do have one you know you can go but
this is more directed for Mark I'm not
like oh good I'm we have a teacher
shortage in this state and we have a
number of pair of professionals that are
working in schools that are saying I
want to become a teacher while we have
alternative Pathways for that we've
spoken with Steve applebe regarding that
however for those folks who decide to
take some of their courses at your level
at the community college level are you
seeing that increasing and if so are
there any issues in the transferability
of those courses that you're taking
because it's not one of those 10 that
been checked off hopefully it's on the
seven that are you thinking closely to
but is are what they do at the community
college system let's say at White
Mountain uh is that able to transfer
into the
PSU education program without loss of
any of the course it is and and U
Plymouth State and and president Burks
and his team have been good enough to
allow students to actually finish
bachelor's program in Berlin uh by
sending f faculty to deliver so that
students from White Mountains don't have
to travel to Plymouth to complete that
bachelor's degree so that that has not
been a problem we're not seeing an
increase but I will say one of the the
Innovative opportunities has been with
apprenticeship uh resource that we have
through apprenticeship New Hampshire
ccsnh is the hub for that activity we've
got a number of students currently
enrolled in apprenticeships uh to become
Educators and it creates another
certification uh strategy for
particularly working adults who can't
afford to take time away to to gain the
credential so most of these people are
adults they're not you know students
coming in at age 18 so when they want to
go get their Junior and Senior year are
there any problems in the
transferability of that coursework to
the four-year system that you're encoun
either with PSU with Keen or with UNH I
I don't believe we're seeing barriers
for that program at this time and again
You're right our adult Learners are are
often tied to the communities they serve
they can't go away to college they're
not going to migrate from Littleton to
you know travel to Durham three times a
week for classes so online is
increasingly important and the ability
for the cours work that they can do
locally to be applicable to degrees
uh integral to the success of of that
we down the roadways we won't be talking
about online I I've seen some of the
percentages of kids that are at at at
students at the community college that
seems to be a program that's expanded
online instruction obviously the
pandemic created a surge in the need for
remote instruction but post pandemic now
that we're down to what might be a new
normal across the system about a third
roughly 30% of our credit activity is
occurring through online instruction it
varies by college from about 22% to
almost 50% High Watermark being at River
Valley uh River Valley has a number of
healthcare related programs draws
students throughout the state so the
clinical is concentrated on certain days
and certain locations but the didactic
the opportunity to deliver the course
content is is increasingly online to
make that more accessible to students
from from greater
distances what speaking of online maybe
we'll get to this but what what what I'm
concerned about is kids at the high
school level at taking these virtual
courses and choosing not to go to
school my my granddaughter chose not to
not to go to school but to take her
courses
virtually and she did that for two years
in high school the last two years of
high
school I find that to be very dangerous
situation you lose sociability you lose
interaction with with teachers as as as
well as uh you know fellow students Etc
are we going to an online World here and
and what what does that present as a
challenge what what the state has
already made a significant investment in
VX yes and for a lot of students that's
a complimentary opportunity for their
education they attend a high school but
it gives them access to courses that
might not otherwise be available allows
them more skill scheduling
flexibility I spent as I said about
seven years at granted State College and
I virtually everything we were doing was
online pre pandemic but if you would
talk to students there's a preference
for sitting face to face often but that
preference loses out to conflicts with
job with family with other
responsibilities I I think that there's
a balance that that that's at play there
where students may prefer to be in class
and with with their peers but but have
to navigate you know those competing
pressures it's one of the reasons why I
think this is a area of growth for the
community college system is that we have
the capability to deliver highquality
online programs but we also have the
opportunity at 11 locations around the
state to have those students physically
sit with their peers with
faculty engage services and I do think
that that's where the world is heading
is more balance of online access but in
person
when you need it and when you when you
can do
it it raises a lot of questions you know
that this one of the questions just pops
my mind I'm sure you've heard it many
times so you have onethird of your kids
online and you have the all these
Capital assets
facilities um which are now maybe half
full or third full whatever it might be
um then we have this deferred
maintenance associated with it all the
questions that we wrestle with all the
time um we currently have uh career
counselors from New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services employment
support Bureau who are regularly on our
campuses uh gives them access to
locations gives us access uh to
informing them about our program
opportunities for the clients that
they're serving um you're familiar with
our Littleton academic center for White
Mountains Community College which hosts
a New Hampshire employment security and
a head start program so we do have in
some instances uh Capital assets
buildings that are larger than they may
currently uh serve but we are looking
actively at where we can build
Partnerships with state agencies with
other organizations whose missions and
and clients align with our mission and
could create synergies that would be
better use of facilities and and create
more value for the
communities are there any more questions
for we're getting into an area that I'm
sure that will be discussed in the
future uh but Mark I want to thank you
very much for coming today and and
taking us through some of that we we do
have some other items on the docket here
which you you may want to get involved
with uh the the next one that we have
and we went through the pathways here uh
Workforce needs and that
uh but we're talking now about Kathy
preventure we're talking about the
the governor's executive order the task
force to realign or to align
postsecondary education in our state and
there's also a follow-up LSR which is
very similar
um I I I don't know even where to start
on this thing Kathy uh sure so so um
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Katherine preventure and I serve as the
chief administrative officer of the
University system happy to be here with
Chancellor Rubenstein um yes the
governor on October 25th issued um
executive order
2003-06 establishing a task force um to
um for a strategic alignment between the
two public higher education systems and
to think about what we need for the
future for public higher education in
the state um Mar chin Rubenstein and
myself both sit on that that commission
um the commissioner of education has
designated Steve applebe uh the director
of higher education in the department of
Ed uh the Senate President has
designated Senator gray uh the speaker
has designated representative lad and
representative luno um community college
system has named uh Nick tus and Ed
Smith from its board and the university
system uh CH board chair has named
Jackie Eastwood and George H
and we uh await appointments from the
governor's office on from two
representatives of business and industry
and um whether or not the governor
himself or a design will serve and the
governor um is also um shall select the
chair of the task force and so uh the
work is to be completed by March 31st uh
I do think that's going to be a heavy
lift for the task force which um
representative lad your lis R may be
completely appropriate to continue with
the work of any recommendations that
come out of this task force by March
31st that's really all we have to report
at this time um uh if we could turn to
page two on the task force that the
governor through his executive order has
put in and the T task force
shall um I think want to make it pretty
clear that there's no
no mention of the word merger at all
correct within this whole process we're
looking at the
investigating the possibilities of what
a strategic alignment might net Us in
terms of enhancing postsecondary
education in this state and so could you
address those bullets under
B uh I I I know that you've worked very
closely with Chancellor Rubenstein in in
some of the the areas that we have there
a the language was tried to come out
mutually
um is there anything there that jumps
out at you or
is uh to be honest with you what jumps
out at me is the bullets under Item B
all should be need to be
considered it's going to be challenging
to to really dig into all those items by
March
31st so I I think the task in my opinion
the task force needs to start
with what do we look like what do we
need a decade from now and how best do
we get there but there'll be there are
10 plus members on the task force I'm
I'm only one um and these items I mean
the executive order require re Ires the
task force to look at all these items so
it certainly
will but time is going to drive how deep
we dive into each one of those bullets
and that's why I think the LSR may serve
as there may need to be
followup after March 31st on on a number
of the
force Mark how do you are you kind of in
concurrence with that that that the the
March deadline i i c that's why in the
LSR you don't see that March date you
see the end of the year however um um
this is a huge huge topic and with all
the issues that are associated with it
right
now the commity comp system board has
already been having similar discussions
uh about what the future looks like and
uh your observation there's no reference
to merger I I'll say that I also I'm I'm
less thinking about what we look like
but I am thinking more about what we
need who the students will be how
they'll be served the discussion earlier
about the non the adult Learners the
Need For Education available locally
online accessible shorter programs I do
think that we are in a period where
higher education is changing what the
demands of what we deliver are going to
be different some of them and I think
that we've got to flesh out what the
deliverables will be what the need will
be before we figure out anything that
has to do with structure if we start
trying to uh make adjustments to
structure before we understand the need
I think we potentially put ourselves in
in the wrong direction so my I I do
think it's a relatively short period of
time and I do hope that part of the work
of the task force is to get a more clear
understanding of what postc education
really looks like in 10 years uh so that
we're building something for the
future and and I will say the the
benefit of the March 31st timeline is
the urgency of the work so again I I
don't think it will be the end of the
work that that needs to be done but so
it it demonstrates there's an urgency
let's start the work in Earnest and go
to the next whatever the next piece of
work is related to
to the needs of our state with
postsecondary high Ed public
postsecondary
highed we we mentioned the word
affordability quite a bit in the morning
earlier
today is affordability one of the
components that would come in for
discussion and when we're looking at the
overall alignment and structuring of our
University postsecondary Systems
um oh I think absolutely that's part of
the public Mission yeah
absolutely I think it's implicit in
raising educational attainment it's
implicit in improving accessibility and
compatibility for students and on the
expense side the avoidance of
duplication the streamlining it's our
managing the expense side so that we can
we can better insulate students and
families from the cost
side
there other questions on this right now
representa well just a comment it comes
to mind in thinking more and more about
March 31st that that is more or less
crossover I think uh for the house and I
know a certain Committee in the house
that's going to be very busy and a
chairman who's going to be uh very busy
during that time period so just budget
that in that's my comment thank
you yeah we'll try to budget that
in maybe schedule it in as a better
word
um it's uh when you take the seven
institutions that you have Mark and the
three Granite State is now merged in
with so we have three there so we have
10 higher education institutions in the
state that serve a
population that's from high school we
have high school
kids involved with concurrent dual
enrollment we you have up to you know
people that are 90 years old still
working at it uh so it it it it's when
you take our state and our population
this
state and you take the square miles in
basis is it
sustainable to have 10 postsecondary
institutions
s and have a you know a source of
Revenue that we currently
have you know is is this structure that
sustainable not not sure how to answer
that question and there there are
certainly larger States but have far
more institutions both public and
private uh than the 27 institutions
public and private here in New
Hampshire um and I said earlier if if
I'm right about the fact that the future
requires more support for adult Learners
and for a lot of those students a
balance of online but local access than
having those touch points around the
state is going to continue to be
important
for um for meeting the need of that
population I I think it's also fair to
say that the print at White Mountains
compared to the footprint at UNH or or
Plymouth they're they're not all the
same it's not 10 equally large so part
of it is not just 10 locations but are
the are the facilities at those
locations and the use for those
locations appropriate for what the
demand will be as I described earlier
we've recognized that we've got some in
some cases some capacity that's not
being as optimally used as it could be
and we are trying to find Partnerships
way to use that space more effectively
for the benefit of those communities and
in doing that we can presumably reduce
some of the overhead for those locations
while sustaining the viability of that
need my answer is I don't know yeah I
don't think a lot of us do I know at at
we're we're looking right now at how we
start well we already have started to
shrink our space we just demolish two
residence Halls at Keane we are
undergoing a master planning effort
across the system right now to think
about how we continue to shrink the
footprint or
so I time will tell time will
tell uh and and I I don't think there's
any need to really go through the LSR
the LSR backup that is to really support
process if it's needed uh the makeup of
that commission uh is a little committee
is a little bit different um but very
very similar
um so represent GL if I may ask a
question yes what does distinguish your
LSR from the executive orders the use of
the word
consolidation and I am interested to
know whether that is part of your
thinking about the future is
consolidation of postsecondary Education
whether that implies merger or if that
really is more just generally your
question about 10 colleges and the scale
footprint I don't think that any
terminology should be taken off the
table um I do believe in consolidation
it can be done internally Within one of
the systems uh I reflect on what
happened with uh the taking the athletic
training program out of
Durham and shipping it up to Don Burks
up in Plymouth State uh are we going to
be able to sustain you know all the
separate types of programs which we have
in education I know the book that you I
maybe you handed out to the trustees uh
Chancellor uh the the book which talked
about Synergy and having to deal with
these situations right off here and
we've looked at
Henderson um the individual the third
party that got engaged in looking
that made the statement within that book
that two-thirds of students in these
universities that he's worked with are
in basically 12 type programs we have a
lot of other programs
and so all those other programs which we
have both at Kean at Plymouth un you um
can we do to the the cost
elements consolidate some of the
programs internally now I'm not talking
at the University Systems but working
collaboratively to try to bring programs
together so we can still have a physical
therapy program somewhere in our state
so we can have these types of programs
that's one way of looking that that that
that that's helpful I just wanted to
understand the intent of the word
consolidation that that makes sense to
me yes represent M well I guess one of
the one of the questions you look at
higher education is you I've got a u
14-year-old and 11-year-old grandson and
granddaughter and I've often thought you
know and what's ahead of them in higher
education and you know one of the issues
I think that we we might be going
towards is that rather than a uh
Bachelor of Arts degree people are
beginning to get all kinds of Badges and
certifications and short-term kinds of
programs that are Hands-On that aren't
not necessarily the the old liberal arts
program that you were prepared really
for nothing and until you got your first
job and that's when you really begin to
realize what what's available there and
so that that's as I've been thinking
about their future that's a thought
that's been going through my head is is
what what what what are they going to do
and I know that the community college
system does a terrific job as it relates
to looking at you know a student can
leave there with a Microsoft certificate
and start with an $80,000 job I'm
assuming and UNH also has been to look
at their programs from a standpoint of
certification programs and so the
question I have what then does what then
is a competition between the community
college system system of badging and
badging that higher education and so
it's uh that's one of the issues I think
as you look at the at this whole topic
is what is that future going to look
like because it may not look like the
same thing 10 years from now uh
particular as you look at the access to
information that we have right now I
mean my wife is is great at at asking
Siri things and I'm I'm I mean I mean we
were in a conversation with a couple the
other night at dinner time and he brings
out his computer he's answering all
these questions that we have with one
another and it it really that begins to
say well what what what does education
mean now with the access of information
so
immedate I do I do think um provos Jones
mentioned it that we uh UNH has a
professional development and training or
Badges and certifications and so there
probably is competition going on um I I
will I will respect ful uh argue a
little bit that there there is benefit
to a bachelor's degree even if it's in
the liberal arts um Beyond just
preparing one for a specific job when
they graduate it hopefully an associates
degree or a bachelor's degree um
reinforces a love of lifetime learning
and thinking differently about things
and being exposed to things that you may
not otherwise be exposed to so I hope we
I hope we don't get to a place where no
one's ever going to college anymore
we're just um I don't I shouldn't say
just but but earning badges so we can
get our next job so I I think that you
know what represent mil we we had a
discussion back in March 27th about an
article that appeared in the Wall Street
Journal and the article was College
doesn't need to take four years and that
was explained by Wayne at that time that
you could do it in three years there
programs you can do that in right now
what I'm concerned about is that I had a
grandson that decided to go to school
outside the state but he was also
accepted at at a college in between
Manchester and Hanover in New
London and and uh he opted not to go
there because at that point in time
there was some really shaky Financial
issues going on within that particular
institution and he didn't want to get
engaged in a program of study and find
out it's pulled out like we've had just
one college pull out within the last
week here in in our state so potential
students want to enroll where there's
going to be a program that's going to be
there four years H three years H six
years hence and so that's that's one of
the concerns I'm looking at personally
is that are we going to be able to
sustain education the way we have it set
up structurally and organization wise
now in this state and can we guarantee
that little Moren here when she wants to
go get her four-year degree is going to
be able to do it and and end up where
she starts or is she going to have to
pull it and go to another one within our
state are we going to are we going to
consolidate any programs we got nursing
in all our institutions right
I think we do we do yeah as I get more
clear on your thinking about the
consolid use of work
consolidation in both 187a and 188
University system Community colge system
the word for our Board of Trustees is to
create well-coordinated systems of
public high education and I think that
maybe that's the word as opposed to
consolidation currently each resp
responsible for uring coordination
within the respective systems and what
I'm taking from this conversation is the
need to assure coordination between the
two systems in a way that addresses that
I said we may not need all of the space
we currently have but I think we need
all of the locations we have because I
think they add value for those
communities as access points for
education so we may scale back what
we're delivering now I'll offer an
example of what coordination might look
like
12 years ago 13 years ago with the last
Great Recession the federal government
was flowing out money to community
colleges through tax Rants and one of
the objectives at the time was to not
create competition among our colleges
and so each College created slightly
different versions of programs which in
retrospect means that we've got a lot of
specialization in a lot of
uniqueness but there's not enough demand
to fully absorb all of that capacity
we've got a couple of Faculty who we
leading an initiative now this involves
robotics automation Advanced
manufacturing to create a core program
accessible to students across the seven
colleges the first 15 credits would be
accessible to students anywhere creates
the foundation includes two industry
recognized credentials that are aligned
with those courses and then allows for
specialization and and focus based on
what a region needs employers want in
that area what a student is interested
in pursuing allows us to create enough
efficiency in that system and enough
coordination to remove barriers for
students and capitalize on some of the
economies of scale that that the future
requires of us those are the kinds of
things that I Envision where a student
should still be able to start almost any
of our programs anywhere but depending
on how specific they want to be may
require that they that they some
accommodation whether that's du online
for access to the more specialized
training or or movement and again with
the exception of Littleton and Berlin
which are fairly remote if you happen to
be you know closer to Manchester but you
could still have access to nhti Lakes
Region we have enough proximity that we
don't need to replicate certain programs
because we think it's not unreasonable
for a student to navigate those
distances it's a huge issue
you know in the state that I came from
New Hampshire would be a small
region and it would be smaller than a
burrow and and so it's it's all mindset
and of course we're in New England which
if you weren't born in the valley you
know and your parents born in that
Valley and your grandparents born in the
valley you probably never serve in the
select board and and that's that's New
England so um I I think there's there's
a need for us to be doing having these
discussions uh if not we're going to and
we we know we're we're headed to some
Cliffs right now in terms of financing
sustainability and we can't be blind to
those so it's time to have some open
discussion and I think this is a good
discussion and I hope the task force can
have equally as prod Ive a discussion
and more so than what we're having just
here just cutting around the edge a
little bit any other yes represent
Mooney just a suggestion going forward
on this Commission in bullet two and it
goes back to an earlier comment I made
that improving accessibility and compa
compatibility for students that also be
included there is advising or tracking I
think that is the deliverable by which a
student can be
assured that they are on track to trans
for and attain their goal otherwise all
of these things on paper sound great the
things on advertisements and websites
and you know take this and that it all
sounds fantastic but unless the student
knows for a fact they're on that path
they're going to miss the mark so I
would just put that out I don't want to
edit a executive order that's not my job
description but if I were I would add
one of those words advising or track
backing to that
bullet thank you you could you could
though okay are there any more questions
from the committee today towards yes
Chancellor I don't I don't have a
question I have a a brief Public Service
Announcement oh yeah um the as you know
president uh Jim Dean at UNH is retiring
on June 30th and the search committee
has been named um truste Jamie Bernett
is chairing trusty Kathy green is vice
chair and they are conducting listening
sessions from for with various
stakeholders to provide input on what we
in the state um are looking for and our
next president of the university and
there is a legislative listening session
tomorrow morning at 10 o' in State House
103 there are also open sessions that
are being scheduled they're going to
wrap up these listening sessions in the
next couple weeks um but the if you if
you search on us UNH president search
the university has a website that has
FAQs and schedules and such that you can
attend open sessions by Zoom also but we
thought it important to schedule
legislative listening session so that's
tomorrow morning at at 10 o'clock in
State House
okay we can try to we could Jen is it
possible that we could get notice like
that out to the education committee
you Al righty um thank you very much
thank you thank you what we need to do
as a high Ed study committee we
are where do we want to go like do we
want to gather any further information
and and when we meet next it's going to
be harder because we're going to get
into the legislative season here uh but
are there any topics that we we want to
be looking at in terms of higher
ed or you just want to just take it as
it
comes oh this this yeah the governance
there was a report that when we talked
merger 2021 I think it was um there was
a report that I was asked to put
together a committee on uh in the
legislature and there was a report that
was issued and that was sent to the
division 2 chairman in that time Karen
umberger and dealt with a lot of the
issues and those issues which we dealt
with are identified uh on on the second
page here under March 27th we did
discuss it here as a group and the
issues that we brought forward were
governance affordability accessibility
vision for postsecondary
Education institutional mission and
vision statements what's the legislative
role and the and that time we were
talking merger merger Implement
implementation and impact and any
recommendations that's all within that
report and it was done um hastily but we
had uh a lot of input at that time we
had the chair of the trustees Joe Marone
came in and spoke we had people coming
up from Nei and presenting their
accreditation we had folks coming in
from the community college system and
University system to speak with us um we
took a lot of lot of input and we came
up with some issues that maybe need to
be looked at too even by the task force
or in this other report because we we
should gather as much as we can to move
forward so I can make that c that that
report available to everybody Mel I
think you were on that
y okay no it was one that we we we put a
joint committee together
from education policy in the house and
and some from finance and we were
looking at this issue and in the report
we we we we gathered a lot I I think
some very very healthy information that
should be considered so I'll make that
available to
everybody
and that maybe we can go from there
forward uh one of the areas which we are
are concerned about too is the
implementation of social studies and
social studies help in the postsecondary
level it's I hope it's one of those
seven that are coming up and where it
says social studies and Elementary aded
that's an important area that we're
we're seeing our kids sliding in that
subject area of civics and government
and geography and history economics and
we we need to really pursue that and we
level okay is there a motion to
ajour boy everybody out all in favor
we're out of here thank you very much
and thank you for coming
today
yeah
what time is
it
really